Hello Freak pitches and,
and again there's comics are there.
I mean there's this comics out there
that are annoying and there's actors out
there that are great.
You're going to have both.
But I just missed that sort
of type of sensibility.
Like the,
the comics,
when you,
when you hang out with comics,
you're always goofing off.
You're always having fun.
There's always like,
everyone's laughing at shit.
No one's no one is letting
anybody get away with anything.
Any fucking where you're like,
you know,
I remember who the fuck was it where
somebody showed up with a hat on?
I think it was Brian Cowen showed,
oh that's what it was.
Brian Keller friend Jimmy Burke,
Brian Count showed up with a hat on
like some sort of like a fedora and he's
like,
get that fucking stupid
thing off your head.
Like what are you doing?
Like what did you think you were doing?
And Brian's like,
thank God he did that.
Because what if I started
wearing that day we were,
we went to shell.
She,
that's the whole fucking day about
New York and tough crowd in all.
And initially we were
there way before this.
But you know the whole comedy
sheller and the fucking Schmidt Kiss,
I don't know,
maybe six months ago,
eight months ago,
Russell Peters walks in and
in Russell's a pretty big act.
It's a big fucking new jack.
He comes in with his entourage and he's
wearing a double breasted fucking pea
coat,
but it's waist high.
And the second we saw it,
Keith,
we couldn't stop fucking smash and him.
Right.
And Russell,
Bonnie,
Bonnie said,
you look like the little
boy on boardwalk empire,
which fuck it.
I fell out of my seat.
Right Keith.
I mean we're fighting now.
He's fucking,
his crew couldn't laugh
cause they could get fired.
They were like,
but we fucking,
it just cause she at the court
and the table to sell on the back.
It's fucking sharks,
you know,
even back,
you know.
So next time he came in,
he's a little more fucking ready.
You know,
Russell's like he started slamming,
you know,
cause that's how he's
not that type of comic.
And,
and I used,
I fight with money all the time
because while everybody's not late,
well fuck it then don't come to that table
because that's what's going to happen
if you come to that table.
I've come to,
I came to that table and I
had a little pimple on my lip.
Fucking Kevin Hart,
fucking poetry's Keith,
not,
they all study on for
us has her being taught,
you're yelling at singing
it in the fucking dark.
Everybody was just a little bump,
you know,
so,
but,
but we would sit up there all night.
It would be me,
Norton,
mainly Keith and Patrice.
Just Smith.
Billie burr.
Fucking Billy comes into the cellar,
right?
And she says,
I'm going to the world series.
It's when the mets were playing
the Yankees in the world share.
He says much.
He goes,
I'm going to the game.
We go,
how the fuck?
How did you get tickets?
He goes,
well,
these dudes hired me to do a show on
their bus on the way in our giving and
right when he said that,
everybody's eyes lit up.
We're,
we,
we did certainly dish.
You guys were a good crowd
and off the bus we beat him to
sweat was pouring down Billy's head.
He didn't do it.
He gave to giggle away.
He wouldn't,
he didn't do it again because
we beat up down so hard.
So I mean it just fucking animals.
Eddie,
if came in there and he started
talking to me and being arrogant,
he's gone.
Uh,
how much did you make or
what do you do with this?
And I go,
well,
I don't know.
I made it.
He goes,
why me and Patrice?
Like he was Patrice said,
tell him he goes,
first of all,
he called him Eddie,
right?
Patrice,
Patrice.
You do colleges p you Versiti
or something or you stink.
I don't know what he,
but he beat up Eddie.
If verbally for 40 no one else jumped in.
It was such a beating.
It was such a busy day.
I was driving home.
I had a call,
nor did I go.
I can't stop laughing so that
you don't get that in La Nicus.
You're like,
in a year you go to New York,
you fucking like you're saying you walk
in when the wrong fucking hat or just
your fucking shirt is too
tight or any imperfection.
Yeah,
they correct.
They're coming out of La and they're like,
oh,
so what do you got?
What's going on?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah.
Not Tell you what's not going
on that fucking hair too.
That's,
that's the,
that's not going on.
Okay.
You look like a Roman nickel.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But you can't do that here.
Well,
you can't have the store.
Yeah.
They even have that,
that,
that comic battle every
Tuesday night at midnight.
That's so packed.
You can't,
you can't even,
people are hanging from
stairways just to hear it.
It's so packed.
And that's just two comics
battling each other.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Stores real renaissance.
Yeah.
To come back.
That cosmic battle was every
night at the shelter at a table.
It's true.
And it was,
but it kept you on your fucking toes.
Don't Kevin Hall and Kevin was
moving from New York to La.
We had a little thing
at Boston comedy club.
Right.
And he's on,
he goes on stage to like say goodbye me,
Patricia and Keith.
It was like 20 phone books
in the back for summary.
We were thrown foam books.
Adam,
as he's saying goodbye and all
your soul solar's phone books,
he did cross the room.
That fucking dumb Kevin Hart.
Okay.
Who's making 20 fucking million a movie,
little fucking news.
So it just makes you,
it makes you a better,
stronger standard fucking
standup because you hang it,
you're hanging with strong fucking standup
and you also recognize the holes in
your game
exposed.
You know?
Not everybody can do that.
No.
You know,
and and I,
and I would fight with
fucking Bonnie called me now.
Me.
Hello.
Are you seriously taking a phone
call while we're in the middle?
There we go.
I'm talking about,
I'm on a gives podcast.
Hi Bonnie.
Oh,
I can hear that.
You just said,
why are you answering your phone?
I thought you said shut that off.
Why would you think it's
an emergency with her?
Because she's driving home.
It's got damn podcast.
Shut that down.
Sorry.
Are you very clingy,
rich?
Like you and Bonnie?
Like are you,
let me,
let me explain something to you.
You don't ever,
fuck,
you've been doing this 10 years.
You luckily have a surprise show tonight.
Okay.
No,
it's just surprises.
You have a show that's a surprise.
Uh,
I know I'm not calling me.
She,
I'm only kind,
I don't mean to disrespect
you and in your home.
Uh,
has there ever been anything that people
have said to you that had stung enough
where you overthink it?
Like,
like when you're doing these battles
and you're getting riffed on like,
like I remember like a long time
ago people were saying like,
your ears smelled and like,
does that get to you?
Like,
oh shit,
my ears smell.
No,
no,
no.
The only time I had,
yeah,
I had a,
I had an all out.
It got pretty ugly with uh,
uh,
bigly on ONA.
He came,
he was doing the virus tour one show.
Yeah.
And it,
and we squashed this,
but it's on you.
We squash it.
But he didn't have the best set that deal.
And I was hosting those shows
and that don't want any slice me.
So he went on and he goes,
what do you want me to be like,
philosophy and work the crowd.
So he started going out to the
crowd and it didn't go well.
So it's not all his fault too.
They put them up towards
the end of the show,
you know,
the show is going for fucking hours,
it wasn't all,
you know,
he should have had a better spot,
you know?
Yeah.
So I mean,
they're not fucking a fucking animals.
They're mutants.
Okay.
Dare fucking their
basement dweller mutants.
Okay.
Uh,
so he,
but then he came into ona and he and
I had been doing this show for fucking
years and he started
making fun of how I talk.
He made some joke and he was being
really arrogant and this and that.
And I go,
uh,
you know,
I started booing and I'm,
I go,
let me make you feel on blue.
And then it just got worse and
worse and it got really ugly.
But he was so passive aggressive about
his fucking swarmy type of fucking humor,
but don't come.
That's like what I just fucking trash,
which I shouldn't have because
he says you're a fucking deal.
This is your deal.
You know,
I'm only kidding,
you know,
a little bit.
And so,
and uh,
but no,
there's nothing that,
you know,
we come from the radio.
I do when I do,
they're all fucking Alamos.
I know.
And a,
everything's a fucking,
you say something wrong
or do this or you're done.
You know,
I heard the first day
back when he sat and,
uh,
Anthony Shared Christie,
he says,
it's fuck him.
I never really liked him.
Anyway,
I go,
let's get this audition started.
Anthony's chairs in fucking long island.
Okay.
Like,
you know,
showed no,
just sometimes fun.
That's what people don't understand.
Like it's,
it's great to be in that company.
It's good times.
People are so sensitive
about goofing on each other.
Yeah.
People are so sensitive
about people cracking jokes.
But if someone cracks a joke
about something that you're doing,
most likely,
the reason why these
things is that you know,
they're right and you don't want to,
you don't want to admit that
you're doing something goofy.
So you get all butthurt well,
the only thing that gets me,
sometimes it's dope.
When I slur or someone,
you know,
may like people on Twitter
think they're my friends.
I think there should,
they try.
They,
you know,
they're not,
you're not Norton.
You're not Bobby.
You're not Billy.
You're not calling.
They're insulting user.
They think of,
and I go look,
you know,
there's,
I think there's a,
uh,
a Twitter handle blocked by Veloce.
Uh,
I black these cocksuckers
all the time because they,
you know,
they're trying to get you to talk
about and which you are even good.
[inaudible] names blacked my boss.
Uh,
so
that's true.
But they got you.
They got me fit.
So yeah,
there's not much,
I mean,
cause I'm a,
I'm a creep.
I fucking,
this is differences.
You're funny.
You know,
and some people do it and they don't
know that they're not being funny.
They just,
some people that,
oh,
you can't take a joke when they're
just being there just being shitty.
It just being like a rude person.
Well it's not a joke and be funny,
you know,
it's just,
I don't know.
I mean,
cause you can't take a joke rich.
I married one in a meanest
female comics on the planet.
She just fucking mean.
That's why we,
you know,
we fight nonstop,
but we come together when we find a
victim that we both want to attack.
When you're somebody that we both
can go after at the same time next,
where our love really
comes out for each other.
That's where you,
you know,
because like when our manager will
call and say something stupid,
we'll just start fucking
attacking them together.
Even when he hangs up,
we just keep it attacking
it until we're done.
And,
and,
and nearshore love,
you know.